[Music]
when we are in a stationary car that
moves rapidly to gain speed we get
pushed back against our seat and when
brakes are applied we get pushed ahead
or when we take a sharp right turn
we are pushed towards the left these are
all situations where we are accelerating
we have all experienced this weather in
a car or a bus or while riding a
motorbike simply put when velocity
changes we have acceleration
I still haven't defined what
acceleration is I just told you that
when velocity changes there will be
acceleration okay let me give you two
examples in the first one a car is
traveling in a straight line at a
constant speed of 80 kilometers an hour
and in the second one a plane is
traveling in a straight line at a
constant speed of 1,000 kilometers an
hour in which case do you think
acceleration is involved
none in both cases the velocity is not
changing at all hence there will be no
acceleration in either of the cases most
people relate acceleration to high speed
and that's clearly not true acceleration
will only exist when there is change in
velocity
do you remember what velocity is its
speed with direction and its hence of
vector quantity why is this important
let's say a body moves from rest and
reaches a velocity of 20 kilometers an
hour in five seconds
well acceleration be involved here yes
because the velocity is changing it was
zero initially and at the end of five
seconds it's 20 kilometres per hour in
another scenario assume that a body is
moving at 30 kilometers an hour and then
it moves right at 30 kilometres an hour
and continues traveling at the same
speed of 30 kilometers per hour
will there be acceleration in this case
Gionta is yes as the direction is
changing the velocity will also change
the only thing constant in this example
is speed but the velocity changes as the
direction changes so this was the most
important concept you had to know about
acceleration it will exist only when
there is a change in velocity but how is
acceleration calculated acceleration is
defined as the rate of change of
velocity in terms of a formula
acceleration can be written as change in
velocity over the time taken if the
velocity of an object changes from an
initial value of U to the final value of
V in time T then the acceleration ay can
be written as V minus u over T said this
object is at rest initially at Point a
it then travels to the right and attains
the velocity of 10 meters per second in
five seconds what will be the
acceleration here at point B we can look
at the formula to get the answer the
initial velocity U is zero meters per
second at the object is stationary the
final velocity V is 10 meters per second
and the time taken T is 5 seconds
hence the acceleration a will equal 10
meters per second minus zero meters per
second divided by 5 seconds so this will
equal 10 meters per second divided by 5
seconds 10 divided by 5 is 2 wait hold
on what will be the units of
acceleration we should get a hint by
looking at this the units of
acceleration will be meters per second
per second because it's the change in
velocity over the time taken as this is
meters per second we can carry this
second to the denominator and what we
will get is meters per second squared
this one is more intuitive but this one
is a bit neater I would say so the
acceleration in this case will be 2
meters per second squared
and acceleration is also a vector
quantity here acceleration and velocity
are in the same direction there are many
more important concepts about
acceleration but we will cover in the
coming videos